what's going on thank you for coming
back and thank you for auctioning off
your million dollar piece of artwork
on uh well go ahead tell everybody what
we're doing today with your art
oh yeah we got all kinds of feedback um
what are we doing what what tell the
audience today what we're doing here
today
and uh what's going on with your million
dollar piece of stolen artwork
what are you doing first of all
i mean you know what it really is what
is it really
really i have like no money coming in
i got turned down for unemployment even
though what
listen to this how did you get turned
down i have no idea like i've applied
multiple times and it's even under
review i just because
here's the thing i was doing okay but
then suddenly like a week or two ago i
realized
i have no money coming in like the next
month i'm going under
practically so so i have no painting
jobs
going right now and uh i actually have
one painting job i actually took the
money for i haven't done the painting
yet i started the painting i just had to
go to utah i had to do a bunch of stuff
anyway
so uh yeah so then you called me and i
said you said hey let's you know let's
do a podcast whatever and i was like
yeah you said what do you want to do and
i said bro i i gotta [ __ ] paint i
gotta i gotta get rid of
i got a painting yeah i need to sell a
painting that's what we're here for so
that's what we're here for
that's what we're here to do ladies and
gentlemen right we are here for nothing
else than to sell a painting
and to help out matt cox wait and i need
people to subscribe to my st my channel
he needs more subscribers and he's more
people to buy this [ __ ] book
on amazon
and i have i don't even know where i'm
at and you know what else i have so
that's me
that's you and you know what else i have
i have merchandise everybody was like
um you know oh if you get shirts and
merchandise great i put up merchandise a
week ago i think i sold a shirt
and i even hit a bunch of people up guys
are like bro i totally support you like
you're awesome you're amazing you're
this and i'm like great
hey i got merchandise you know you want
to buy a shirt for 25 bucks bro go to my
thing they're like yeah bro as soon as i
get paid
as soon as you get paid it's 25 [ __ ]
dollars bro i mean honestly if you don't
come on it's 25 bucks yeah i know you
got
i know these guys all got unemployment i
know guys that are making 700 bucks
a week plus they're getting they got the
trump check
oh yeah i mean what's going on we're
getting another one i you know i paid in
last year for like 400 dollars to
self-employment for self-employment
taxes
god damn i they turned me down
all last year and they turned me down
the system's getting there they're
getting get back on you
for all that money you stole from this
[ __ ] but you know what
i guarantee i gotta make my restitution
payment
did you get a trump check me yeah
not on camera what no oh no i got a
trump check oh you did
oh yeah the generation officer knows i
got a trump check okay
because she i said hey do i have to pay
my restitution on the trump check she
said no
nice danny said we're getting another
one
yeah or bobby was it me i don't think it
was me i didn't hear it i did hear we
were getting another yeah i heard it was
in july
well july is almost over almost over
yeah i don't know when that so i'm not
sure what's happened with that
so tell us about your painting we got
here today
oh how what inspired that piece of fine
art
see let's see see you you run with it
i'll bet you're great at it
man this means you sell it first
you sell it first then we'll have luke
try to sell it this is the joker
wearing the joker mask in the dark night
when he robs
the bank at the beginning of the movie
where all the guys have the joker mask
and he's got one too
and you don't really realize it's him
till the end well actually you kind of
know it's him but anyway he takes it off
at the end
and the movie kills each every person
kills each other
as they complete their job he gets the
gets the money he takes off it goes off
perfectly with a perfectly prepared plan
by a complete sociopath
and uh perfect that's it and that's
that's the quote he says at the very end
of the bank robbery
which is whatever doesn't kill you
simply makes you
stranger and it's great and it's on
youtube too
it's got like 10 different clips of the
somebody you know they've posted it
so it's great that's it that's i'm not
that great
and you thought you mentioned earlier
that you thought that was the
perfect bank robbery right yeah that's
why is that the perfect bank robbery
well i don't know if it's a perfect one
i love the bank robbery from heat too
um you know that says class isn't an
amazing movie
uh oh you know you know the other one
the inside man
you ever see the movie the inside man
the guy actually
stays in the bank after the robbery he
builds a false wall oh yeah i have seen
that
amazing that's a good movie amazing the
whole movie takes place in like one
one location right right yeah at the
bank it's perfect it's a great
it's a yeah it's a great film anyway
people love the joker and uh uh people
keep comparing me to the joker and uh
you feel like you can relate to the
joker i can i do i feel like
we're kindred spirits i told you about
the the chick that
well the the the um
the this producer who like wanted me to
do a
uh host like a show and we we had a
whole discussion
about the show and what it would be and
i was like man i loved her idea of the
show and then after she went and started
pitching the show
it changed to suddenly where i'm like
i'm a guy trying to turn around uh
businesses that are getting robbed or
something it's like what
i was like no no no no no i'm not doing
all that
you're not no i said you're trying to
make me sound like a boy scout i said
no i said i i was okay because before
you were portraying me kind of like like
the joker and now you're trying to turn
me into the boy scout and
i don't i'm not gonna i can't be a boy
nobody's gonna believe that
you've heard me talk nobody's going to
buy that i'm no i'm trying to do the
right thing and
you're being taken advantage of and i
want you to i want to help fix your
pro i'm not going to i can't do it i
can't do it
so anyway yeah we need to sell this
painting
how much uh i i need 600 for it but i'll
take more
luke what are your thoughts on this
painting luke also has a fine arts
degree so what do we do we just have
them bid
in here or what yeah they're bidding
right now it's at 125
125 are you serious 20. 20 nice
honestly honestly that's nice honestly
yeah like it like this too is that the
canvas alone
costs you know 80 bucks you know the
canvas you know the canvas and the
acrylic paints the time the material the
total materials on the
total materials yeah with with canvas
with the paint probably 110 110 100
bucks 100
you know it's hard to tell because you
buy a you buy a
paint brush and matt signed it at the
bottom paint brush you're using the
paint brush
but it's like the paint you're not using
a whole tube of paint but you're also
you're using at least there's probably
at least
eight different colors in there so each
one each things
eight or nine different eight or nine
bucks
eight or nine uh um
different uh tubes of paint you don't
use them all though so whatever probably
around 100 bucks
110 100 bucks something like that
you want me to sell it yeah sell it for
us so matt told you
what it is and i'll tell you what it
means yeah
all right this is what you learn in art
school folks this is what you learn at
leo burnett selling marlboro cigarettes
or leo burnett so the interesting thing
about this painting here is the the
three clowns that we have here all
interacting with each other you have the
leader out front
who is you know the strong dominant
presence of the group
and he is leading the group and on he's
got weird fingers
okay i got it so this is kind of like a
combination of all the different
personas that matt has embodied
over his criminal career you just
switched the strong
leadership role in the front and then he
has the two hesitant ones behind him
hiding behind this leader
they don't really know where they're
going and they're not fully in focus and
fully in color yet so they're not really
strong enough to be out there on their
own
so i like to imagine this front more
dominant character
is emblematic of who gary sullivan was
at his peak like during the
performance this is gary sullivan he is
strolling into bank of america right now
fake credit cards
fake ids and just a head full of steam
because he knows he's going into that
bank and he's getting exactly what he
wants
and you know you see the texture in the
background with all the laughing
that's matt when he's leaving and that's
why it's to his back because he's
leaving the bank
laughing with millions of dollars wow
that was
better than what i did that's better
than mine yeah some guy just said six
hundred bucks
gary sullivan i made it
keep it going keep it going it's worth
at least that's really set you gotta
you gotta actually send it in in the uh
in the chat
well we're gonna at the end whoever's
got the highest oh okay
so how are we gonna do it so how are we
gonna actually clean the transactions
you do he's from yeah you also
understand that you have it has to be
shipped yeah
yeah the problem is luckily this is not
they're going to ship it for free
it might shipping is probably i mean
i'll work it out with the guy i mean
it's probably going to be 80 to 100
bucks
at fedex david now if it's local you
know
great but if it's not if it's like keep
in mind it's about a hundred bucks to
ship this thing so
i've shipped a couple canvases that were
five foot by four foot to texas
and a couple to illinois those were
about a hundred and
thirty 120 to 130 how many hours did you
put into
that that yeah yeah
so we just asked god i don't know that's
[ __ ] hard to say bro
i don't know it's hard to say bro what
to say because i don't sit down at one
you know it could be anywhere between
two
don't do it in one sitting yeah don't
sit do it in one side you paint a little
bit
you do something you come back you paint
the paint has to dry and you're thinking
about it you're thinking about it you're
thinking what the canvas doesn't mean
you're not working
right because let's face it this this
isn't a picture i didn't pull this
picture off the internet yeah you did
project it and then paint it you know
that everything's you know it didn't
come out of your imagination
yeah well the the the face the mask came
off of
um came off the movie you can find those
online somebody said two thousand
dollars if you accept in five minutes
if you accept and fight if you he
accepts that
i accept two thousand of course like if
you want to pay two thousand dollars to
this right now then
do it absolutely you gotta deal with the
same guy he's out
twice already he went from six to a
thousand to two thousand
you see me look you send two thousand
dollars right now we stopped talking
about the painting where it's gone i'm
completely different
yeah you got the painting and i'll pay
to have it shipped paypal the money
now pay it pal and i'll send
and give you the book and we'll
autograph it wow that's a bargain
you